العلاقه بين بكين واشنطن صراع نفوت سيتحول
لعداء ام علاقه تنافسيه فقط الرئيس
الامريكي بايضا تحدث عن امكانيه اذابه
الجليد في العلاقات لكن قبل ايام اعلنت
تايوان او وصول اولى شحنه صواريخ ستينجر
الامريكيه راتبكين في ذلك ما يتناقض مع
تصريحات بايدن
نعارض بشده اي نوع من التعامل الرسمي بين
الولايات المتحده ومنطقه تايوان كما نرفض
اي تعاون بين الحزم الديمقراطي التقدمي
الحاكم واي قوه خارجيه
اذا الاجواء مشحونه وبحر الصين الجنوبي
الدليل الاكبر اتهامات متبادله بين
الطرفين بكينه اتهمت واشنطن بمراقبه
مناوراتها وواشنطن اتهمت مقاتله صينيه
بتنفيذ مناوره عدوانيه قرب طائره عسكريه
تابعه لها هذا التوتر زاد اكثر برفض الجيش
الصيني مجددا ترتيبا لقاء مع وزير الدفاع
الامريكي ونظيره الصيني في سنغافوره وهو
ما صفه عليه واشنطن بحسب
مصره على عدم ترتيب اللقاء طالما استمرت
العقوبات الامريكيه ضد وزير الدفاع الصيني
والتي فرضها عليه ترامب في عام 2018
وابلغت واشنطن بذلك
اعتقد ان الحادثه تظهر اهميه ابقاء خط
اتصال مفتوح بما في ذلك بين وزيري الدفاع
في البلدين من المؤسف ان الاجتماع الذي
سعى اليه الوزير استون مع نظيره الصيني لم
يتم
بجانب اجتماعي وزير اي دفاع البلدين كانت
تحوم حوله
الازمات
كان الاتفاق التجاري الذي وقع بالامس بين
الولايات المتحده وتايوان اعلنت منتصف
مايو ان وزيره التجاره سيتوجه لواشنطن
وبعدها بنحو ساعتين تم الاعلان عن اكمال
المرحله الاولى من الصفقه التجاريه اثار
الامر غضب بكين حتى تم الاجتماع الذي قال
الطرفان عنه انه كان مهما لابقاء قنوات
الاتصال مفتوحه لكن رغم ذلك الاتفاق
التجاري الذي وصفته تايوان بالتاريخي
سيكون صعيدا للتوتر بين البلدين فهو
الاكثر شمولا الذي يوقع بين تايبي و
واشنطن منذ عام
سيسهم في زياده التجاره بين البلدين من
خلال تنسيق الضوابط الجمركيه والاجراءات
التنظيميه ووضع تدابير لمكافحه الفساد
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات